[Music]
this is your life paper airplanes when
did this obsession begin tell us it's
just never ended really I started at 9
or 10 like most people and I just never
really got over it
so at 9 or 10 like everyone else who
started making simple paper tape roll
paper airplanes and then you just kept
going and going and going yes and now it
is just pretty much taken over your life
my life my house my yeah everything yeah
okay when did it first get serious when
did you turn the corner from I'm just
gonna make a simple paper airplane to
I'm going to really build something
special here it kind of a new layer sort
of happened when when I started studying
origami I wanted to sort of up the ante
a little bit and no one had really done
high-performance planes with just
folding usually people get arrested in
cutting and pasting you know and they
they give up on just folding to make air
foils and so I thought wouldn't be cool
justice to be able to take all those
tricks from origami you know the ancient
art of Japanese paper folding take it
back to high performance paper airplanes
okay are you you have a family you're
married how's it work the number one
question people ask on YouTube is am I
still a virgin yeah well what's what's
the answer there okay good
okay you have the record for longest
indoor distance flown by a paper
airplane which was 226 feet and 10
inches a little more than 75 yards yeah
well I just said that yeah we have a
clip here of the winning throw should we
just take a look at this right now this
is the winning throw this time let's
take a look there it is there it is we
are all over that one that's going to do
it get up there get up there get up
there get up there get up
[Applause]
oh my god
I love that there's a color announcer oh
that was you just lost your mind and
then the celebration afterwards was just
pure insanity it was a three-year
journey i Joe I think he's a three-year
a journey a three-year journey yet a
three-year journey three year journey
you didn't throw the plane who threw the
plane Joe Ayub is here in the audience
somewhere Joe is the my thrower where's
Joe he become a professional airplane
thrower he was actually doing color
announcing for an arena league game okay
Irene a football he played arena ball
heap also played for Cal great
quarterback and so he was the third
quarterback the first guy had gigantic
hands and was kind of crushing the
planes and the second guy had such a
snappy throw he was actually ripping
planes in half and so for the last 18
months I worked with Joe who who
actually modified his throw and worked
out a way to sort of finesse this thing
dropped his elbow quarterbacks you know
throw with an elbow up position so and
he had to work on smooth acceleration
and so the plane could withstand all
that you know that power okay now you
have a bunch of planes here arrayed all
around us do you want to show us Wow
look miss these are very precise those
are yeah that one just turns me into a
[Applause]
cuz we get the direction lean it over
we're over
oh yeah yeah alright what else we got we
got one that plays out flips over flies
back upside down well that's it does
that every time
pretty much well unless you throw it
don't tell me how to do that just really
really gently kind of at the monitor up
there just a little bit up okay and then
we gently yeah like you're gonna throw
it about ten feet there you go
[Applause]
this is why you'll fire you made a fool
out of me this is why you hire a thrower
you see it's what's this one here this
one is kind of fun what's this it
undulates yeah I think I'd call that one
humpy so that's actually the same the
same folding technique as this and when
I was at Red Wings or Red Bull Finals in
Austria somebody was throwing that in
the aerobatic finals and I thought I was
the only guy who had invented a flapping
airplane and it turns out that's just
folded with taller paper so that the the
break in the layers hit but happens at
the leader I would have guessed as much